Let's go next to our caller from the nine
five one area code.
A caller from nine one a.
Where are you calling from?
What's your name?
Oh,
okay.
Um, is this for me?
That is indeed you.
Oh, hi.
My name is Billy.
I'm from California.
Hey Billy.
What's
I have, I have two questions.
Um,
and Billy, we're not on speaker phone or we
were, I can't imagine we'd be on speaker phone
right now.
No, we're not.
There's a fan in the building I'm in.
Can you hear that?
Is that what you're hearing?
I don't know.
It just, it sounded like you got very far
for a second there.
It sounded like what?
What's your question, Billy?
We're ready for it.
Okay.
Sorry.
Um, the first question is a coworker mentioned
that if we removed minimum wage hike, things
would be better as a nation because, um, something
about, uh, floors, economic, artificial floors
are bad.
Uh, it prevents people from negotiating true
value.
It increases unemployment, that kind of thing.
Listen, all of those arguments, did those
strike you as good arguments?
No.
So that's part of where I'm kicked.
Cause to me something about it seemed kind
of fishy.
But I have coworkers who are like, hey, some
of this is sounding like it makes sense and
I don't actually know anything about economics.
So I figured, Hey, I might ask an adult who
does.
Yeah.
So the first thing I would do is go to Google
and type in debunking minimum wage price floor.
Okay.
And you will find a way, wealth of information
about that.
It is true that in a classical economics framework
you can put a very convincing looking graph
together, which will make it appear as though
that is the effect of a price floor.
The reality is we are almost at full employment.
We continue to be almost at full employment,
even in places that have 1112 and $15 minimum
wages.
And what you have to understand is that there
is a very particular in, well some people
are maybe or are acting in good faith, but
there is a very particular bad faith incentive
to make these arguments by people who just
don't want businesses regulated and they want
businesses to be able to pay three, four,
$5 an hour.
And the fact that you can have such an unequal
and problematic, uh, economy that people would
be willing to work for three or $4 an hour
doesn't mean that it's the right thing to
do or what we should be doing.
And that's the important thing.
Yes, if you remove the minimum wage, you will
see a company's paying less and people accepting
it and being willing to accept that.
But the longterm implications of that are
not good.
The, the long term implications of that on
crime are not good.
The longterm implications of that on government
benefits spending on welfare programs aren't
good.
So you need to zoom out in order to really
understand the context of those talking points.
Oh, okay.
Um, and then my other question was about health
care.
One argument that was made is that because
we have health insurance, it allows companies
to charge us really high prices and if we
didn't have like a health insurance base and
instead people paid like out of pocket themselves,
um, it would drive prices down or something
because these companies would still have to
sell their products to people and if they
can afford less, uh, or something, it would
drive prices down.
Yep.
That's that, that's a total free market solution.
And that might work, uh, when there, when
demand is not as inelastic as it is in healthcare,
but healthcare is different than it.
Healthcare should not be treated as a normal
market because basically if you don't need
a hip replacement, you don't care whether
a hip replacement costs a dollar or $1,000
or $100,000.
If you do need a hip replacement, you're in
a relatively small group, right?
It's still not everybody needs hip replacements.
And all of a sudden what it costs has no impact
whatsoever on how badly you need that hip
replacement.
And this is the reason why those sort of free
market lezafaire ideas simply shouldn't even
be in the picture when we're talking about
healthcare.
And most western developed countries have
already figured that out.
Um, maybe I didn't quite communicate what
I'm trying to ask correctly.
It's the idea is like if people can't afford
[inaudible] insulin at the current price,
wouldn't healthcare industries or something
lower the price and that the only reason they
can get away with charging like a high price
is because insurance companies can,
no, that's not, that's not the only reason.
And this is related to multiple different
levels that we've, we've analyzed in detail
and this includes, uh, the fact that there
are, yes, insurance companies do negotiate
certain rates for products and in order to
get a certain reimbursement rate that causes
an incentive to make the sticker prices higher
and higher.
But it's, it's far more complicated than this.
Um, and uh, we've got a couple of videos on
it that I would, I would encourage you to
check out.
No problem.
Thank you for your time.
All right, appreciate the call.